welcome back to cbs mornings a racial
discrimination lawsuit in northern
california highlights an issue that many
african americans have complained about
for decades home values set too low when
the owners are black tanisha tate austin
and her husband paul say a white woman
who appraised their home set its value
at less than one million dollars so they
ran an experiment if they had a white
friend stand in as the homeowner would
that raise that number and a werner
shows what they found
this was completely different paul and
tanisha tate austin have been remodeling
and improving their marin city home ever
since they bought it five years ago so
you open this up open this whole thing
here yeah
gut it the entire kitchen
so when mortgage rates were low in early
2020 they jumped at the chance to
refinance something they had done in
2019 to take advantage of the home's
higher value generating more cash for
additional improvements that year it
appraised at over 1.4 million dollars
but now a year later just 995 000
and when it came in so low we both were
like oh this is this is wrong and so the
impact of that number for you
was what
significant i mean it's it's it's the
it's the financial impact but it's the
emotional impact it's the feeling every
day like the tax of being
african-american
in this country like you don't know it's
it's a coin toss you're not for sure
what's gonna happen
so for a second appraisal they decided
to do something they felt would get them
a better number for sure with the help
of a friend named jan you said let's do
what so i just said to jan i was like i
we we had a low appraisal will you
be me she's like of course i'll come
over
and the thing to know about jen is
she's white
with jan now playing homeowner they
cleared away their own photos and art
we had to take down everything yeah like
all of our art that you see around our
homes pictures anything that's
essentially resemble
that this home belongs to a black family
it's like anything
that was reminiscent of you and what you
care about yes you had to take down yes
after what they call their whitewash the
new appraisal came in nearly 1.5 million
dollars close to half a million dollars
more than the appraisal roughly a month
before
you feel a sense of relief like i i told
you but then you feel a sense of sadness
like oh my goodness like i can't believe
that it prays for we had to do what we
had to do in order to have our house
appraised for
yeah what it should have appraised for
from the start it's messed up
right like we shouldn't have to
you know i mean it's
you might as well say it's heartbreaking
and they say it proves the first
appraisal took race and historical
demographics into account in violation
of the fair housing act they're now
suing the appraiser who is white
claiming she used unsuitable racially
biased comparable home sales or cops in
determining their home's worth giving it
a low market value
they're not the only ones whitewashing
their homes to find out if they'll get a
better appraisal black families in
indiana and ohio did the same with
similar results a recent study finds
homes in the nation's black
neighborhoods are often undervalued by
an average of 48 thousand dollars it
left me just
with a realization that america hasn't
you know gotten as far as it may think
it has when it relates when it relates
to race
cbs news reached out to the appraiser
and the company for comment but have not
heard back we really want people to
understand that you the the practices of
the appraisal system
perpetuates black people people of color
from being able to build wealth in their
communities and that has to stop
for cbs mornings i'm anna werner in
marin city california
i think he said it best when he said
that's messed up here we are in 2021 and
this is still an issue yeah yeah there's
painful emotional distress that they're
going through but then when you think
about the generational wealth that they
are trying to create
and sometimes there are these roadblocks
that are thrown in our way yeah it's
tough to deal with yeah i like he was
wearing a button that said i love marin
city which is the town they're in uh you
know they're trying to invest in their
home which is an investment in the town
which is an investment in the whole
community yeah and the difference too in
the price too is what got me the
difference in the approach 500 000 it
wasn't just a couple of bucks that was a
lot a lot of money